can you imagine what it is to run a
non-profit on a daily basis today I want
to talk about what entrepreneurs startup
entrepreneurs can learn from those who
run a nonprofit organization I'm
petrified of you host of value taming
this past week I visited Toronto Canada
and then I went to Jacksonville and Fort
Lauderdale in San Francisco in during
that trip I was visiting several other
entrepreneurs startup entrepreneurs
business owners and a question was
brought up question was brought up is it
harder to run a non-profit or is it
harder to run a profit organization I
asked the question this a person who
runs a non-profit if we took them and we
planted them in a profit would that
person do better than a person who's
been in profit all day long going into a
nonprofit let me explain to you why
there is a lot we can learn from
nonprofit organizations especially
start-up entrepreneurs lots to be
learned from nonprofit organization I
came up with six there was a lot of
points but six main points I came up
with on what we as startup entrepreneurs
can learn from different nonprofit
organizations leaders to lead nonprofit
organizations first ones this if you if
you around a leader of a nonprofit
organization they cannot help but talk
about their cause and the purpose of
their nonprofit all the time there is no
way in the world you can be around a
nonprofit organization leader anybody
and have them not talk about their cause
sometimes you know profit entrepreneurs
they're gonna talk about profits they're
gonna talk about business they're gonna
talk about their revenues the numbers a
nonprofit knows what gets you to get the
funding is you have to constantly talk
about your purpose and your cost
sometimes startup entrepreneurs talk too
much about the business but how - not
enough about the bigger picture there's
a lot to be learned there from what
nonprofits do no matter when they talk
to second thing about nonprofits it's
very unique that we can all learn from
as a start-up entrepreneurs because they
work with volunteers every day they're
constantly having volunteers that come
they end up becoming very very good
teachers of teaching the basics
reason why is because in the corporate
world you're gonna train somebody you
don't need to teach them that thing
anymore they're already good at it then
you have to teach them something else
and then something else and then they're
set they could say what you're doing the
same thing for the next 5 10 15 20 years
that's not the case with nonprofits
nonprofits are dealing with 10 20 30 40
50 100 300 400 500 thousand 2002 it put
volunteers so they're always teaching
the basics so here's I say this here's
how you fold this here's how you do this
so nonprofit organization leaders become
very good teachers because they're
always teaching when they're dealing
with volunteers and they become very
good at teaching new people startup
entrepreneurs can learn a lot about that
on what they do the next thing what
nonprofits do sometimes startup
entrepreneurs we tend to you know
success comes and in the family France
people say you know I'm doing this I'm
running a business I'm running this I'm
running that and more people start
hyping you up and you start really
thinking you're there and compared to
other people you may be that way you're
not there yet and that ego prevents you
from asking for help so we no longer
want to ask for help or sometimes even
new rookies startup entrepreneurs don't
like to ask other people for help
because you're not supposed to ask
anybody for help
well anybody who runs a nonprofit
organization they are always asking
people for help
hey Mary do you mind helping us thought
about this hey John do you have a couple
minutes yes I just need your help do you
mind if you help us out for this project
please if you could really help us out
we would definitely appreciate it oh
definitely what can I help you out with
we needed three people who can come out
and help us put these things up you know
no problem I'll send 30 people over hey
Jackie look we need your help can you
help us out we're looking for somebody
who can help us bring in a B team we
just don't have a budget for it can you
bring somebody so they're always good at
asking for help sometimes startup
entrepreneurs they think they don't have
the right to ask for help and you can
always ask for help when you're smaller
you got to ask a lot of people for help
when you're getting me you gotta ask a
lot of people for help and sometimes so
reciprocal you're given help to another
person to partner up but here's another
things nonprofit organizations do very
well that startup entrepreneurs can
learn from they're very good at
stretching the money they're very very
good at stretching the money
they can put a $20,000 event together
with $1,000 as startup entrepreneurs
sometimes tends to put a $20,000 event
together with $50,000 does that make
sense a non-profit stretches the money
how can we work over here how can we do
something about this part what can we do
to get volunteers in this but who can we
get that can help out with this for at
the beginning stages of a company being
an entrepreneur yourself you're attacked
with money you can't spend a lot of
money a lot of different things so you
need help as much as possible to figure
out how you can stretch $2,000 $3,000
$4,000 because you don't yet have
capital $400,000 for million dollars or
40 million dollars to be able to do the
bigger things you need to learn how to
work with the $4,000 or $40,000 to
stretch it nonprofits are very very good
at breaking it down and trying to get it
to be as tight as possible here's
another thing that started a nonprofit
organizations leaders do very good at
they eventually because they ask so many
people for help and yet reject it
because they ask so many people to raise
money with and they get rejected because
every day they're told to no guess what
they become immune to we become immune
to rejection it doesn't bother them no
more because to run a non-profit you
cannot run a healthy nonprofit without
being rejected every single day whether
you're running a church whether you're
running a nonprofit organization for a
cause and a work it doesn't matter so
many people will regularly say no to you
so many people will constantly say no to
you and you still got to be able to
learn how to deal with it and then last
but not least nonprofit organizations
they see a lot of people come and they
see a lot of people go they see a lot of
people come and help out for a few
months and they're gone another person
comes in another person comes in another
person comes and eventually they find
the right leaders within a non-profit
that buy into the cause because they
can't stop talking about it that
eventually that person who was a
volunteer they get promoted to a leader
they get promoted to somebody who wants
to run maybe a director maybe a person
that's managed in different parts of the
nonprofit because their hearts now in it
then they become leaders but they don't
emotionally get attached to somebody
coming in and somebody leaving I
sometimes see entrepreneurs you know
that guy he was gonna kind thought he
was gonna do this and he left oh this is
why my business is not gonna work you're
too attached to one person nonprofits
they appreciate it great you came we
learned you gave some time and helped
out and you move on and when you think
about those things and you think about
what nonprofit organizations leaders do
I would tell you if you know local be
any nonprofits that do very well on
you're an entrepreneur take them out to
lunch treat them out to lunch that's my
suggestion to you treat them out to
lunch for one hour ask them questions
questions such as how do you ask for
help how do you raise money when you ask
people to voluntarily give $1,000 $2,000
but how do you do it how do you get
people to volunteer their time to help
you on how do you go through having a
you know such a thick skin with doesn't
bother you you would be amazed how much
you will learn from somebody who's a
leader running a non-profit as a
start-up entrepreneur it'll help take
your business to whole different level
so if you're known about in the startup
entrepreneur world share this video with
them because when they watch us they're
gonna say those are all the things that
we're pretty much immune to doing and
there's a lot to be learned from them if
your startup if you're somebody that's a
nonprofit or you're running a non-profit
and I didn't cover one of them comment
on the bottom I'd love to hear what else
you think US startup entrepreneurs can
learn from you that's my message do
weekend please don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and comment on the bottom
you